Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 31st,
2017 what's going on?
How are you?
What's going on?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
How is she a summer?
Huh?
Is it going to be a heat wave?
The heat's coming back.
All my God.
Please try to stay in shy inside the air conditioning.
If you don't have air conditioning,
please try to remember to keep your windows open and stick your head through the
opening in the window,
not in the solid part of the wall.
You know when they do that shit on the news and they try to help old people not
die in the summer,
he what?
A fucking way to go.
You'll live almost a century and yes,
you know,
you've lived through the wars,
you've lived through the depression,
you've lived through a,
the fucking New York in the 70s and all that.
What finally gets you a hot summer day and yeah,
just sitting there
and you just can't,
you just can't get to the window.
It's like when you'd watch wrestling,
right?
And it's one of those tag team wrestling matches and the guy just can't get to
his teammate to fucking slap his hand like Tagamet.
That's what it is.
And they dad said,
they lay there,
they find them face down in wrestling trunks.
The greatest generation stormed the beaches of Normandy taken out by a fucking
heat wave.
Does it every year.
How many heroes?
How many years people are we going to put up with the sun?
Taken another one of our heroes away.
I swear to God.
You know,
maybe if there was a different administration,
they would handle the threat of the sun,
right.
My talking politics now,
is that what I'm doing?
Let's talk politics.
Why?
Why do we keep fucking with this Douche in Korea?
Why don't you just leave him alone?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
It's like when you're on the subway and the crazy guy comes in the car,
you don't look at them.
You don't start talking to them.
Just fucking leave him alone.
Leave him alone.
It has nothing to,
why don't they just let the fucking guy,
you know,
run his country the way he wants to run his fucking country.
Send some food in their feed.
The fucking people.
Why does he have to have the same fucking ideas about strip malls that we do in
order for us,
for us to get along with them?
Huh?
Haven't we proven that?
It doesn't matter what kind of government you have in the end,
there's going to be human beings running it so they're going to selfishly fuck
the whole thing up anyways.
Who gives a shit?
If he's over there,
lighten off.
His fucking mad is let them do it.
The guy is clearly unbelievably insecure.
He clearly is,
is trying to follow in the footsteps of his dad's giant fucking shoes.
Although he's probably smaller.
I don't know how tall this guys are over there,
but whatever tall for over there.
Big Shoes for North Korea,
especially with all the lack of nutrition that's got to stunt the growth of your
fees there.
Right?
Why don't they just fuck it.
You know
we should like when he shoots something off,
we should just feed his ego.
Oh,
hey it go.
Where'd it go?
The Kim Jong Il this second.
Whenever you fucking name is.
Hey you fatty case.
That was a good one too.
That set you like that.
Look at,
look at ours.
It's awesome.
Fist bump.
Good man.
Hey,
it's a uh,
here's a copy of that last year's Superbowl.
Check it out man.
It's fucking amazing.
What do you got?
You got Gangnam style DVD.
You want to trade with us?
Why can't we just try to get along with this guy?
What is the fucking problem
like?
We give a shit.
What the fuck he's doing to his people?
These kinds who run shit over here.
They don't give a fuck how many people are upside down in their own house.
They didn't give a fuck about the people in New Orleans.
They give a fuck about those people in North Korea.
Now.
They do not.
No,
they do not.
You know what it is that they're sitting on a bunch of material that you could
turn it to.
Those doctor does beats by Dre.
Goddamn it.
We want it.
So that's what we're going to do.
We're going to act like this.
Fucking God damned Fatso with his fucking three missiles is going to be a
problem.
MMM.
Yeah.
And I want us to just leave the guy alone.
They're talking now,
right?
According to Google news that I didn't even read it.
All I did was just click on it.
It says US allies paired to use overwhelming force in North Korea.
General says,
uh,
we're prepared to shoot a bunch of missiles in his general area,
says the general hoping that one of them lands on him and we kill his few
innocent people as possible.
They would never say that the US in its allies are paired to use rapid and
lethal,
rapid lethal and overwhelming force if necessary against North Korea.
The commander of the U S Pacific air forces worn Saturday night.
And why are we doing this?
Cause this guy's shooting off his own fireworks cause he's testing missiles the
way we do a North Korea remains the most urgent threat to regional stability.
O Shaughnessy said,
o Shaughnessy,
you've done it again.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Do we really got to go in there and blow this guy up with a bunch of other
people just trying to fucking get to work.
It's gotta be another way to do it.
Don't,
don't,
don't we have any James Bond's guys that can just kind of go in there and start
banging the hottest chicks chicks in North Korea is they subtly try to kill him,
you know?
But the power of his dick is so overwhelming.
They forget to kill him.
And then he realized that by the time they realize I was supposed to kill that
guy,
but I was so busy having orgasms.
Right.
He's already out the door.
He's got the pass codes,
and then he goes down there.
How would you kill that guy?
How would you kill that fat bastard?
No.
Okay.
You know what I would do?
I give him a honey of a ham.
You know,
the glazed ones that they have around Christmas except in the glaze would be
some sort of Sinai.
That's where you hide the poison,
you know?
And he would just be staring at it and he would just,
mouth would be watering so much that he couldn't wait for the official taste
tester to give it a try,
you know?
And he would literally die while making himself a sandwich.
You know,
when you're so hungry you making the sandwich and you already fucking thrown
chunks of meat in your mouth.
That's when he would be doing,
so it'd be two prices.
What does,
does he look?
He looks like a white bread guy,
doesn't he?
He's definitely not a multigrain,
you know?
Do you think he gets an everything Bagel on the way to work every day?
I hear a hairless bastard.
I bet he doesn't even have to wear deodorant.
You know,
there's a lot of things to like about him.
He's fat,
you know,
so he's non threatening,
that means he likes eat strikes to fucking stay up late and Netflix and chill.
You can see that about him,
you know.
Do you think he knows how to dance?
Have you noticed that about little people and uh,
in fat and fat people,
they transcend race when it comes to dancing,
you know,
it's like white guys can't dance pretty much general unless they have fat or
they're a little person,
then all of a sudden they're just fucking,
it's just like,
wow,
will you in the beat at video,
what's going on here?
It's because they had to,
that's what happens.
You have to visit certain amount of ice cream that you eat where the laws of
nature just take over and at some point you have to learn how to dance or you're
just going to be heading into an abyss of sadness that,
you know,
there's not enough chips Ahoy or in the world can fill that void.
Or is it that they get that sweat into the oldies Richard Simmons thing and that
just kind of launches this talent.
They didn't know this is just for fat people.
I don't know about little people.
You know,
little people could sit down at the ground,
they can see the steps easier.
You know where like when Michael Jackson First Moonwalk,
you know,
everybody was as tall as Michael Jackson,
so we couldn't figure out what he was doing with his feet.
But little people down at the ground,
they lie,
I got that shit right.
And the next day you're in the subway.
Don't,
don't,
don't all bone bone.
When it was like fucking eight little people all coming at you and you,
did you ever see that?
Do you ever go into the subways of Brooklyn and there was a bunch of little
people doing recreating the bad video?
Know that Jack Golf [inaudible] I'm bad.
No.
What's going on?
I'm going to stupid mode.
I'm trying to say.
How would you North Korea.
Okay.
I have no idea.
You know,
it's funny.
He's like a baby.
He's like baby fat.
That's what I like about that guy.
Like if you wore shorts,
it probably looked like,
uh oh cutie pies there.
Are you getting ready for a nap?
Woke up.
Oh,
you did?
You did.
You want to go to Brooklyn today and watch us eat real people food while you
keep drinking milk?
Um,
all right.
Was that all right?
No,
I dunno.
I Dunno what I was talking.
I was talking about some fucking stupid shit.
Um,
yeah.
So why,
why
like honestly what would happen if we just left that guy alone?
You know what would happen if you just,
I'm seriously asking this.
If you lifted all the sanctions and he was able to trade with the world and they
were able to fucking get some food in there,
whatever the fuck's going on.
If you just honestly just let him do his shit.
I mean,
we shoot off fucking missiles all the time.
We don't use oil.
Yeah.
We,
no,
this is what kills me.
How do we even know what the fuck he's doing over there?
Who is fucking time to be watching this shit?
Can you imagine if that was your Goddamn job and then you'd go on home on the
subway and then you sit next to me and you're watching me losing my shit cause I
can't download the new operating system.
And you're sitting there dealing with the fact
that there's some chubby little fella on the other side of the world shooting us
some shit that could possibly be on its way over here right now.
I Dunno.
Do you think if the animals had the abilities,
they had the ability to shoot those missiles,
do you think they would do it in an effort to try to wipe all of us out so they
could just go back to fucking catching trout in a stream?
You know,
if there was going to be an animal out there that would betray us,
which,
which species do you think there would be?
You know,
it have to be something,
at least at the level of a bear.
Reptiles are out reptiles of like,
you know,
Bill,
they're,
they're like,
you know,
there's those kids that go to the,
the,
the like reptiles have like learning disabilities,
right?
They have like fucking dyslexia.
A Dee Dee,
you know,
they like the riddle and kids of the animal kingdom or they even considered an
animal is a reptile and animal.
I always forget this shit.
Any Amphibian,
right?
An Amphibian is something that can uh,
be,
uh,
it's like aqua man,
right?
He's out of the ocean.
He's talking to a dolphin and then later on that night,
you know,
he's getting Sushi.
I'd be fucked up,
right?
It's on a Daikin Sushi this date.
Sitting there looking at him like,
you know,
you just seem like you're somewhere else.
You just got like the weight of the world and he's sitting there going like,
I wonder if I'm eating somebody that helped me out one time.
Remember that Shit.
For some reason they would all come and help them.
They never really explained that.
Did they,
why they all liked him?
Why they would interrupt whatever the fuck it is that they were doing to stop
some other fucking people in a boat.
Is it bringing in a key of cocaine or some shit into the u s and it's just like,
like
a whale doesn't even know what cocaine is.
Why is it going to get hurt its tail smashing this boat?
Because as much as it could smash the boat,
this,
this pointy stuff,
right?
There's the master and all of that.
He could hurt himself
and all he gets is a thank you.
You know,
does aqua man go,
hey,
thanks a lot.
By the way,
there's a bunch of plankton over their little heads up.
No one's seen it yet.
Ah,
thank you.
Welcome.
And he never did it.
You just be like,
oh,
thank you.
How fucking insecure these God damn fish.
MMM.
Here's another thing too.
I'm sick of fucking hot.
Newscasters,
male and female.
All right.
What do you,
what are you trying to do here?
You know,
I don't need to be aroused when I'm fucking listening to world news.
Holy Shit.
What happened to that fucking Lady's face?
Oh,
it won't go down.
Come on and go down.
Scroll down.
Oh Man,
I,
I don't,
I don't get how to use computers.
There's something on the side.
Where is it?
Where is the lady?
All right.
And Arizona woman played dead.
All right,
wait a second.
Oh,
this is all this click bait stuff.
Kendall Jenner's nude photos,
sparks who gives a shit?
She really is the best looking one of all of them,
isn't she?
No offense to Kaitlin.
Um,
all right.
So I guess now we're going,
so we're going to,
we're having a war with Afghanistan.
We're having one with Iraq and now we're going to have one with North Korea.
You know,
this isn't this like when Ho home depot opened so many fucking locations,
they'd like started putting each other on a business.
MMM.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
We're going to do another one.
We're going to start another one.
I right.
What are you going to do?
Ag?
You know what the fuck I guess.
I mean,
what do I know?
I'm just another asshole with the podcast.
Just trying to struggle through an hour.
MMM.
You don't even really wish I've just wished like,
you know,
why can't they just do it?
There's some guys shooting off his,
you know,
like it just go fucking do it.
Stop dragging me into it.
Showing me what this guy can do and how his missiles can fucking,
you know,
he's a Roman candle.
Can fucking somehow land on my house.
So what,
what does that do for me?
Micah supply what?
Up on top of my house.
Like a hurricane is coming.
It's Christ.
You were in the fucking Navy,
you've got,
that's your job.
Is it world news when I can't put together my new hour of stand up.
Oh,
shut up.
Go Fuck Yourself.
What do you want from me?
Um,
so anyways,
so my,
my daughter was,
uh,
grabbing onto this pleather couch that we have here.
All right.
Cause she's learning,
she's learning to crawl.
And uh,
it was funny,
she was like plank and today,
you know,
doing like,
not like what the kids did on the Internet.
We just laid face down,
face planting is what I thought it should be called.
She was like literally doing,
she was in upper push up position.
How about that?
The upper push up position.
Um,
and she was learning something and you know,
and I should've just let her figure shit out.
Instead I went,
there you go,
there you go.
And then she just dropped down to the floor,
looked up to me and smiled.
I was like,
it just distract her.
So anyways,
they got this pleather couch here and her fingernails are really long.
And,
uh,
and she was making that thinking nailed down the chalkboard sound and it was
driving me nuts.
So against
my gut,
I decided to cut her fingernails,
which I do.
Nia has told me to do what I said,
I don't want to do it.
If things are too small,
she wiggles him around at it.
It's,
I don't want to do it.
So I got the first four done correctly and then I did her thumb and she made
this face and started crying and I looked cause she was wiggling her finger and
I thought it was underneath it.
And I,
I just,
uh,
just gave her the little s little little cut on a valve.
Got and now the families here,
I gotta go get some pizza.
I'll talk to you.
I am I really going to pause in this right now.
So I made like a little cut on a finger and,
uh,
it was,
I probably the worst feeling I've had as an adult
and um,
you know,
when she was fine two seconds later,
but for the rest of the night,
every time she cried,
I was convinced it was because of that little fucking scratch I put on a finger.
MMM.
Worst fucking feeling ever.
And I don't know why I had to pass it onto you,
but you know what,
if they could sit there and tell me that this little fucking fed shit over there
was shooting off as a,
I guess that's what you do.
I'm going to let you know what's going,
everything awful that's going on in the world and I'll let you know what's going
on in my world.
That was awful.
And,
uh,
all right,
I got to get off the,
uh,
hang on a second.
Hang on one second.
Let me see what's going on as far as people who are coming over.
Jesus,
I got too much family here to keep going.
I'll try to go for another few minutes here.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So that happened.
And um,
just to immediately stop.
So now she has like short fingernails at one hand and long ones on the other
end.
I'm trying to get my wife to clip the other ones.
She hasn't had the time and it's driving me nuts.
Okay.
Statically.
You know what I mean?
It's like the fact that like,
the fact that five of our fingers,
I have short nails and the other five don't is driving me fucking crazy.
I don't know why.
It's the same thing.
You know when black guys walk around with their pants hanging off their ass like
this,
that you just want to pull them up,
you know?
And then the white guy version of that is those white guys that walk around with
this shoe's untied it fucking,
I don't know why it has no effect on my life.
I don't know what it is.
It drives me up the wall.
Pull up your pants.
I,
you fucking sneakers.
Okay.
Just can you be an adult?
MMM.
Do you ever seen those guys that take it to the point?
Literally they have a long shirt on that goes past their ass and then they have
a belt.
It's like,
I don't know how they can still walk.
I saw a guy one time,
his pants were literally below is junk.
Um,
I dunno,
it's crazy.
Kids,
you know,
I guess they guys,
they have to keep taking it further than the generation before.
I figured at some point that someone's got to be a rebel and go the other way
and you start yanking them up,
you know,
til you do the old man thing,
what's right underneath your man boobs.
Um,
anyways,
you don't want it became fascinated with since I got here because New York has
changed so much with all these glass towers.
Um,
I got the tallest building in Manhattan.
This is new.
They used to be this place called the Drake hotel was Zeplin and all these guys
stayed.
And uh,
this place that replaced it is four 32 park avenue
and you can have to see the fucking views of this place.
It's so,
it's so tall.
Like you can see the roundness of the world or the flatness,
you know,
depending on what you believe,
you can see the end of like,
you know those people that I think they think we kind of live in like a giant
Coffee Cup.
Is that what it is?
You know?
I mean there has to be like even people who fucking don't think it's round,
it's gotta be half round,
right?
Like you kind of tennis ball in half.
Then you just filled it all in with land and ocean.
Right.
But they think it's like that.
I don't know to this building on the top floor,
they have this,
this website.
I think on a clear day you could almost see the Tappan zee bridge.
You actually look over the freedom tower past the statue of Liberty,
pass that and island out to the ocean and the top floor.
I remember I already talked about
since podcast went for $95 million.
I think you get the top two floors or something like that.
And then the floor below it,
the apartment below it,
second highest one,
there's still for sale at 85 million bucks.
And I think in the reason why that isn't selling is who the fuck is going to pay
$85 million to still have some asshole walking on is it's sealants can get
fucking keep it down up there.
You know
some rich guy walking around.
I think you know they probably that I would think at that point
you could literally be wearing tap shoes and like it's so expensive.
The person below you can't hear it.
They gotta have some sort of soundproofing are spongy floors.
I don't know what it is cause I know people who are that God damn bridge would
not tolerate listening to somebody walk.
You probably have a herd of horses up to the person below it wouldn't have it.
So it's probably the reason it's not selling as they just can't handle it.
They can't handle view of that kind of money.
You want to be the swinging dick in your building.
There's somebody else above you drop it as jumped on your forehead every time
you walk out the window out the door,
can't have that.
Um,
what I did find interesting was that the,
the building was so tall that he actually had to call the FAA.
Um,
cause I learned last time I was out here,
I flew up to a Gig and a helicopter.
Right.
I just want to see fly with the George Washington bridge just to do it.
And he said
Bravo airspace,
which would be LaGuardia.
JFK in Newark was 900 feet and above.
And this building's like 1300 and change.
So it actually literally goes up into commercial airspace.
So at nighttime there's like these floors that are always lit,
just pretty cool.
And I don't know if that's because of the,
the FAA or what,
they usually just have like blinking red lights on the top or something like
that.
Like,
Hey,
don't hit this man.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know who,
who has,
who has that kind of money?
Who is that kind of money?
How long is that elevator ride?
And also how long before somebody base jumps off the top of that thing
and if you did,
could you make it out to Ellis island?
Actually,
you know something as far as like jumping,
that's not that high up.
If you're going to try to fly right when those guys don't,
they usually jump off.
I'll time Ron Burgundy.
I wanted to shout it from my mom pack.
Don't they?
A don't take the jump off a mountain.
They go all the way down a mountain.
Right.
Jason Isbell,
you've really talked yourself into a corner here.
How would you,
yeah,
I have,
you know what I was going to do last week I was going to sing the praises of a
water taxi,
which I think I did a water taxi about how great it was underrated taking the
water taxi in New York from,
from Manhattan to Brooklyn or vice versa there Manhattan out to New Jersey.
Whatever you want to do.
It's awesome,
right?
And no sooner.
And I took the local to where we made like 10 stops and it took an extra half an
hour,
but it was just relaxing.
And it was beautiful.
MMM.
I made the mistake of saying how great it was in like three days after I said
that one of those yellow ones,
the guidance slowed down in time and he smashed into the dock and like 30 people
got hurt.
Uh,
which means really probably 12 got hurt the other 18 and looking for a payday.
This guy just came cruising and he was probably texting.
I just don't understand how you screw up that bad
with the bowl.
There was the,
the,
the weather was fine.
It was a clear day.
Like what did you do?
Okay.
You just came cruising in that,
that there's probably the guys last run of the day,
the chickies been texted,
he wanted a,
her,
she finally texted him back,
Hey,
what are you doing?
I'm at a bar on peer,
whatever.
Yeah.
And he was like,
oh fuck,
it's going down.
Oh Shit.
Wait.
But goes flying,
you know,
and the boat I was on,
the guy driving it,
he's just like surrounded by glass.
So it's not like,
you know,
airline pilots,
when they have a hard landing they just won't open the door and they just stay
there,
you know,
so you can't seem,
cause then he'd go into the jet way.
When you're on a boat there's nowhere to hide.
You know,
people just walk by and he'd just been loud.
Sorry about the js is a sorry about that.
Everybody laying on the ground.
Um,
I know I'm not supposed to laugh at stuff like that,
but the end of the day I wasn't on the boat and no one I know got hurt.
So there,
there is something kind of hilarious about it unless somebody gets seriously
injured,
you know,
he's just going to spark an internet controversy.
Now is it going to brew be a group of six people that complain all at the exact
same time and it gets picked up.
You know,
we're going to go to war with North Korea,
but first podcasting,
can it go too far?
Um,
all right,
25.
I'm trying to get up to 30 minutes here cause I don't have any of the
advertising right now.
And I don't have any other questions either.
Um,
the New York Yankees are crushing it,
ladies and gentlemen,
they are a,
they were down five games to the $200 million Boston red sox.
Uh,
my $200 million Boston Red Sox,
your $200 million red sox.
Okay.
Cause when teams start spending that kind of money,
like it's got to come from somewhere.
It can't just come from red sox fans.
It even comes from people who are not red sox fans.
So anyways,
um,
they,
I dunno,
we,
we lost so many fucking games in a row.
We finally one last night,
Saturday night,
I'm recording this Sunday and uh,
one nine to eight actually scored a bunch of runs for once,
but the Yankees at just surgeon,
but they're only up by half a game and there's like,
I dunno,
900 games left.
We'll see what happens.
But I'm more of watching the Yankees all week on the yes network here.
One of my favorite things to do,
watch them and root against them.
It's what I always did.
And when I get the baseball package,
I'd lived in New York for so long.
It's hard for me to turn on the red socks because I,
for so long,
my baseball watching was watching the yes network rooting against the Yankees.
It's bizarre.
Um,
and somewhere in there,
sweet Caroline came out and I don't know,
this is just a bunch of weird shit that happens at Fenway now.
I went away for too long and I came back and I just don't recognize it,
but I am back into it.
And,
um,
I really wish our team would just focus on trying to win and stop getting into
arguments with Dennis Eckersley.
All right.
He's a hall of Famer.
He's,
I love what he does.
He's great at this job and I don't mind that he criticizes the fricking players
and uh,
Jesus Christ.
It's like all these stories that they,
you know,
people are here,
get the fuck outta here.
Yelling at him and on like the team plane and everything.
Like why would you do that to a hall of Famer?
You know what I mean?
If he,
if a hall of fame standup comedian criticized my act,
I would listen to him and be like,
all right,
well shit,
evidently only I need to work on some stuff.
You know what I mean?
I certainly wouldn't start screaming at them on the team,
a comedian plane,
which is basically a commercial airliner.
Um,
all right,
I'm going to take a break now because I got to go out with the family and uh,
I'll come back,
I'll read some advertising and some questions and we will wrap it up.
I have not watched the f one race yet cause I don't have the channel.
And like I mentioned earlier,
you know,
I dunno a lot of people that are into it,
none of my friends are,
so no one's really going to ruin it for me.
But if I had to guess,
I really,
I hope Lewis Hamilton didn't win again.
I hope he's just not going to run away from this thing and it just becomes
Mercedes,
Mercedes like it did last year.
Uh,
I hope federal one,
you know,
just to keep it,
keep it exciting before they go on the break or whatever.
All right.
That's it.
I'm done babbling.
I will,
uh,
well for you guys would be like two seconds.
I'll be back in two seconds.
All right.
A and I'm back.
I hope this isn't too loud.
Fucking the battery ran out.
And my other thing,
and this is me continuing on with the Monday morning podcast.
Oh lovely.
Mia,
how are you this morning?
I know you're not in a good mood.
She's not in a good mood.
You know every couple when you travel,
there's the one person that's freaking out that wasn't going to miss the plane.
And then there's the other person who could like give a shit and he is the one
that freaks out like,
oh my God,
did we leave enough time?
Did we bring extra batteries in case there's no flashlights on the planet?
Like I don't even,
I don't even know what airline were.
Delta,
are we in Delta?
I don't know.
I never fucking go.
You know what,
I on the way to the airport,
when the driver goes,
you know,
I always know what airport I'm going to for the most part.
Uh,
the dude just goes,
what you're like and that's when I check my itinerary,
my itinerary.
I am going on virgin.
I am going on.
You Knighted.
Ooh Mommy baby.
All right.
So since I last talked to you,
which was yesterday,
uh,
the Yankees,
the Yankees lose,
but so did the red sox were still a half a game though,
by the way.
New York sports press enough with the judge.
Shit.
Jesus Christ all rise.
Then they have this thing,
you know,
cause he's got the gap between his teeth.
They like the tooth,
the whole tooth and nothing but the till we get it.
His last name is judge Jesus fucking Christ.
Why is,
why do sports pages get away with puns?
You know,
every fucking other day they got some stupid pun on the back of the sports page.
Cause they can't write a fucking joke when they shouldn't be able to cause the
sports writers,
she's just tell me who won the game.
Okay.
I don't need you to say,
Oh gee,
oh golly Jeter.
Like why is it always have to be a pun
sitting in there?
You're all a bunch of writers.
You can't come up with anything better than that.
The tooth,
the whole tooth and nothing but the tooth.
Okay.
Oh,
just like fucking,
it just ruined my God damn day.
I hate when I record just off my fucking computer.
This fucking God damn air conditioning will not shut off.
Just shut off already.
So fucking loud.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Why is it still on mode?
Hello?
Hi.
Fall low.
There's no fucking option here off.
Sorry.
Just fucking this fucking God damn Americans.
It either doesn't work or it's drowning out conversation.
You know what I mean?
It's like somebody you just hope it's going to pass out,
but that last 10 minutes before they do that,
just interrupt and everybody.
So this fucking air conditioning is like,
um.
Anyways,
let's get to some of the advertising here for this week.
Uh,
where the fuck is it?
Ah,
that's not it.
God Dang it.
Come on.
We can do it.
Oh look.
Oh look who's here.
Oh,
would you look at this?
It's so zip
recruiter.
Are you hiring well?
Are you um,
do you know where to post your job to find the best?
Not the,
we'll settle for this person.
Not the person who you know.
Well,
at least he put deodorant under one arm pit.
We want the best one,
the smartest,
best looking,
most fuckable candidate.
Right?
Who's kidding?
Who,
that's what you want.
You want people who know their job,
how to do it correctly and who look good.
That's what you want.
You know,
regardless of what these feminists might say,
regardless of what these fatties want to talk about,
at the end of the day,
you want a good looking fuckable reliable employee.
And that's where zip recruiter comes in.
How is ZipRecruiter different?
Well,
I'm glad you didn't ask.
I'm glad the copy asked for you with Zip.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology or their basic or shit on the Internet.
Oh,
we'll call it powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your
job better than anyone else.
And that's why zip.
Okay,
I shut my fucking tooth.
My wedding ring is different.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
It goes out and grabbed him by the balls and it finds them.
In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter.
Get a qualified candidate in just 24 hours.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with zip.
Okay.
Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with immediate results.
There really is,
and right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter for free.
That's right.
Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more
time.
Hi,
Zip.
Okay.
Dotcom side.
Alright.
Oh,
movement watches.
MVMT watches pronounced movement was founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
Movement watches start at just $95 at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks movement figured out that by selling online
they were able to cut out the middleman and retail mockup providing the best
possible price.
Classic design,
Quality Construction Style minimalism over 1 million watches sold in 160
countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to
movement.com/burn this watch has has a really clean design.
Seriously.
I've been getting compliments ever since I put it on.
Um,
no,
no.
Now is the time to step up your watch game.
Go to movement.com/for join the movement.
And lastly,
but not leastly the original advertisers of this podcast.
It's stamps.com stamps save you time and money,
which can you,
you can use to grow your business.
I Shit,
I can mail any letter,
any package,
just using my computer printer in the mall.
Mailman comes and picks it up.
I was reading so well,
now I'm going to fuck up this last one.
Avoid the hassle,
man of the post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease.
No long term commitments.
Click print mail,
and you're done.
No need to lease an expensive postage.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm sending out my posters,
if I'm going to pour myself out after a show,
if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you,
because I'm not smart and right now,
you too can enjoy stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four
week trial,
four week trial with a jury of your peers plus postage and a digital scale
without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstampsdotcomenterpaperstamps.com
never go to the post office again.
Hey,
how bout it for Oj Simpson?
Ah,
he's out again.
What's he gonna do?
He's out again.
He's going to kill that one.
But two,
he's out again.
It's Oj run for yellow lives.
I love when he said,
you know,
I've,
I've lived in a pretty confrontation confrontation free life and that is true
other than when he killed those two people.
I mean,
he was a hell of a Gotcha.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Let's,
um,
let's read some of the questions here for this week.
Uh,
microchipping says revelation 1317 is called mark of the beast.
Now,
sorry for this.
Click here.
This is going to be loud.
Block your ears.
Three,
two,
one.
Click.
Uh,
what the fuck is it?
I know.
I looked it up.
There we go.
Revelation.
This is the exact reason why I don't read the Bible.
A library.
Revelation three 17.
Let's see if I can get this here.
Okay.
The temple of God was opened in heaven and there was seen in his temple,
the arc of his testament,
the arc of God's testament is the holy of holies.
The second apartment of the sanctuary.
I,
you already me.
Okay.
Evidently you can rent a room up his church in the,
you know,
or he has one of the tenant,
uh,
in the ministry ministration of the early Tabernacle,
which served unto the example in shadow of hip of heavenly things.
This apartment was opened only by the Great Day of Atonement for the cleansing
of the sanctuary.
Yeah.
Therefore,
the announcement that the temple of God was opened.
Okay.
Well,
there you go.
So I guess that explains my shipping.
Thank you Bible.
That really is the good book.
I mean,
I would,
I think I,
okay.
I think I understand like computers more than I get the Bible.
I just,
why can't they just write it in fucking today's English?
They do that with every other book of lies.
No kidding.
All right.
I work for the microchip company in Wisconsin.
Okay.
Some stick fuck offered my boss a TV show.
Uh,
what the fuck are they going to call it?
How to shed your employee's rights.
Thanks asshole.
Sorry.
Just venting.
Love your stuff.
Thank God for your gifts.
You don't pledge a clock for Satan will need neither deal with you.
Just work for a company in Wisconsin quick the fucking job they want a lot.
Do I dunno.
Collect unemployment and not be microchipped come on,
people don't give Delta Airlines your fingerprints.
All right.
Please don't do this.
People,
please don't give into this.
Don't go to Tiger Stadium and give them your fingerprints so you don't have to
stand in line for a fucking pretzel.
You fucking dope.
And please don't be dumb enough to think,
well do my credit's fucked.
Good luck of somebody steals my identity dummy.
They're going to create a false credit report.
All they need is to Lee Harvey Oswald depended on which will be you and your
fingerprints.
Your fucking dope.
Yeah.
You know,
in the future there's going to be a knock on the door
or,
and they're going to question why you killed a hooker and the Ukraine and you'd
be like,
I've never been there in my life.
Oh yeah,
your fingerprints were,
but uh,
but up,
up his,
this story of a person who didn't kill a hooker.
Now he's getting banged in the ass in the Ukraine
cause he left his finger prints at the ballpark because he wanted a course.
Like,
all right,
I'm sorry.
All right.
Vacuums gathering information.
Okay.
Uh,
hey,
big ball.
Billy thought you might enjoy this article in regards to your recent podcast on
companies and fingerprints.
Now it seems like those robotic vacuums are selling maps of the inside of your
house.
Okay.
So you can get furniture ads.
Yay.
Um,
massive Aussie fans can't wait to hopefully see,
see you when I go over to the u s in spring of 2018.
Yeah,
things are just changing.
So frigging rapidly.
You know what's really going to be interesting is when they microchip everybody,
okay,
they microchip everybody and then they put all the cash.
There's no longer any cash.
What's going to be interesting then is all these fucking,
you know,
drug dealers,
all these fucking,
I dunno anybody who just didn't trust banks and put a sack of money in the
fucking wall.
What do you do with that now?
You know?
Now it's all on you now that's not even worth anything.
You've got to show up with all this shit.
They'd be like,
hey man,
where did you get this money?
And you're gonna be like,
Hey man,
I earned this money and I already paid taxes on it,
man.
And then going to be like,
hey man,
you got to prove that and like,
I can't,
and then I'm going to be like,
hey man,
fuck your bag of cash.
What's going on?
Nino?
And you like my song above microchips due to due to a don't is this story.
Ah,
you just walking around,
you're getting ready and yeah,
you get so nervous on days what we fly,
Jesus.
Okay,
well that was fun.
Yeah.
So anyways,
at least fucking lazy ass fat fucks by these computers that just,
these little robots,
that fact that sweep up after him,
you know,
as they're written like Ritz crackers with like ice cream in the middle of it.
Whatever fat people do,
right?
They're always creating some new foods on a holy matrimony of cock carbohydrates
and fucking sugars.
MMM.
They're too fucking lazy to get off their ass and use a vacuum cleaner.
So they have this robot do it and then they map the inside of this person's
house,
you know,
so they can do what with it?
I don't fucking know.
So they can sell them an l shaped couch.
In fact,
people sit on l shaped couches.
Can they swing their leg up to that?
You know,
that other side of it?
I don't know why I'm making part of the fatties today.
Maybe because I started with that fucking guy over there and uh,
whatever his fucking name.
I don't even know the guy's name because it'll lead,
you know,
cause he's crazy.
I don't need to know about this guy.
Um,
we should get him to come over to the fucking Detroit Tigers ballpark and his
fingerprints.
Then we'll put it on something that will go over there and we're a restaurant.
We'll stick them in Ojs old self.
MMM.
How mad would he be?
You mentioned that guy ever went to jail,
just standing there.
You know
all that hair on top of his head,
but nowhere else on his body,
you know,
he's one of those weird hairless adults.
Right.
All right.
Girlfriend broke up with me because I like your podcast.
Thanks me.
Thanks for helping me weed out the Kuntz mate.
Come back to SK sometime.
Saskatchewan.
I hope you enjoyed it.
There girlfriend broke up with me because I like your park.
I would like to heard more details on that one.
Okay.
What was it that she didn't like about the podcast?
My annoying voice.
My tone deaf sagging.
My inability to read out loud.
Um,
alright.
Addiction to on like prostitution to shit took should dear Trojan bill.
Over the course of the last year I've become addicted to online prostitution.
Juicy exchange is Christ too.
The courage you have,
you just go online.
Yeah.
She would just have her come over to your fucking place.
Like you're ordering it.
God Damn Pizza.
What is it like when you look through their fucking hole and you see her walking
down the fucking hallway,
the whole and your door or whatever you call that thing?
A little side thing.
She comes stumbling out of the elevator.
Um,
it started off as curiosity.
What would it be like to fuck a stranger for money and snowballed into me
spending a percentage of almost every paycheck on hookers,
anywhere from 60 to 3,300 try to stick with the $300 hooker.
You really get what you pay for.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Here's the story
of a bunch of venereal diseases.
He said,
I broke up with my girlfriend a few months ago.
She had no idea,
but I didn't want to drag her into this.
Well,
Jill,
you can't fucking do this.
When you were in a relationship with somebody,
you said,
I recently got tested and I came up clean.
Thank God was what I was going to say,
and he wrote it to thank God.
No one knows what.
I Bet I do this and I'd prefer to keep it that way,
but I can't help myself from going on to those websites and meeting with these
upper,
these women.
I feel like it's getting worse every month.
It's already cost me my relationship.
It's costing me a fortune and I'm too embarrassed to ask anyone I know for help.
What should I do?
And I'm sorry if Nia is in the room and completely disgusted by this.
I'm pretty disgusted with myself too.
All right.
This is what you have to do.
The second you wake up,
you got to rub one out.
All right?
And then you go to work and at lunch you go,
that was delicious.
Excuse me.
And you excuse yourself.
You go in and you rub one out at the,
in the bathroom right now,
unless you can,
unless you can't lock the door.
And then when you come home,
rub one out again.
Okay.
And then that's it.
And then you take your fucking phone and you throw it in the freezer.
If you have a landline,
you rip it out of the wall.
Um,
I actually,
if I was you,
it's like this is like
if you spend spending this amount of money,
I would just,
uh,
I would go to a therapist.
Okay.
You know,
I'm just say,
yeah,
I'm addicted to online prostitution.
I mean therapist to hear everything.
Okay.
That's actually like,
that's like easy listening music to them compared to some of the shit they have
to,
you know,
people come in there and talk about how they got molested by one of their
parents.
I mean,
it's crazy shit.
You're just like,
hey,
you know,
I like bang and hookers so it's costing me a lot of money and I'd like to stop
and they'd be like,
oh my God,
you're sort of functional by all means.
Lay down on my couch and let's fucking talk about this.
Why do you feel you want to get prostitutes?
Why wouldn't you want to be with a real girl?
A regular woman?
Um,
all right.
I snooped through my husband's phone.
Isn't that a song,
isn't it?
I snooped through my husband phone and I liked it,
That's fucking [inaudible].
Good morning Billy.
Uh,
on Sunday morning my husband had his work phone alarm set to 5:30 AM of course
the only person at wakes up is me.
After I turned the alarm off,
I decided to go through his phone.
You fucking pores do we go through your shit is self.
There's such fucking horse.
I have to admit that it wasn't my proudest moment.
All right then I forgive you.
You're a nice person.
Um,
see,
let me just jumped around.
But I am insecure while looking at his message,
I see that there are texts from a phone number without contact information and
quickly figure it out.
It is his ex girlfriend's number and the text message.
There's a lot of flirting as well as my husband complaining about my appearance.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Well this is what you get for snooping and eventually asking her to get drinks
together while we were visiting his family for father's day in their hometown.
Okay.
Oh Jesus.
They were together for six years on and off through college and high school.
She cheated on him more than once.
Okay.
Um,
then when we got together,
she harassed me on Facebook and took an eight hour bus ride to try and meet me.
Oh yeah.
So this bitch is crazy and she's great in bed.
That's what's going on.
I had to ignore all my initial reactions toward her.
And just ended up ignoring her.
I didn't want her in my life.
I confronted him about it and his only response was why would I go into his
phone?
And then if I go looking for something,
I'm going to find it.
Jesus Christ.
When I asked him why he did it,
he just said he didn't know.
He has ignored me ever since.
I'm not sure where to go from here.
Thank you.
Uh,
you are amazing at colossal cluster fest.
Too bad you didn't get to finish your set.
Hopefully you're in the bay area.
It gets them all right.
You know something.
I apologize for calling you a whore 15 fucking times and all of womanhood,
doors.
Um,
well he's not leaving any doors open here.
I guess what I do is
Nia.
Oh,
she's too busy packing.
I Dunno.
What do you do here?
You're married.
You obviously you have kids,
unless you were just visiting his father for father's Day.
MMM.
Well,
he's being a total bitch about it.
I can tell you that.
Yeah.
MMM.
I think you kind of need to have the what the fuck conversation like,
uh,
do you think if you'd just like,
ignore me,
this is going to go away.
Well,
hey,
you know,
what'd you snoop through my phone for?
If you're looking for something,
you should find some.
Well,
yeah,
well I did and I did.
Would you say that to the cops?
Hey,
we found a kilo of cocaine in the trunk of your car.
Well,
what the fuck are you going to the trunk of my car for him?
Yeah.
You fucking look into something.
You've got to find it.
The cops going to be like,
oh,
okay.
MMM.
Fucking deserves to give you a fucking explanation.
A little better than that.
And then you just sign if you want to work through it.
And if he doesn't want to work through it,
fucking dump his ass.
This,
this,
this is the best you can do.
I mean,
come on,
you're better than this.
Anybody's better than this.
Okay.
Fuck this guy.
All right,
fuck.
Is this kid a guy?
Get off pulling a move like that.
No response like that.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't,
I don't get that.
That's 100% not fair to you.
Fuck this guy.
Okay.
And I'm not saying to leave the guide,
but if he's not going to discuss it with you,
then the fucking relationships.
All right.
The trust is gone.
Um,
all right,
good luck with that.
And I'm sorry you're going through that.
That's,
that's really,
uh,
unbelievably painful.
And that's one of the worst fucking responses ever.
Splash.
A little legendary.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm teaching guitar to a cute girl.
Oh,
Jesus.
Please tell me she's of age.
I don't like the sound of this are ready.
Right.
Hi Bill.
I've been listening to your podcast for a while now.
Just picturing this old guy applying Ben Gaze.
He listens to this and now,
no.
Uh,
and I now know you lend,
you tend to give some solid romantic relationship advice.
So I was wondering a few,
it may be the lovely Nia too,
if she's around,
could help me out with this.
Way about two years back,
I met this girl on my wet,
in my last year of university.
We had a lot of the same classes together,
so we started talking.
We have a lot of the same interests.
She's really smart.
She's funny and Nice.
He just all around my type,
but it turns out she had a boyfriend so I backed off pretty quickly.
To this day we're friends and we try to meet up every couple of weeks.
Is just when Harry met Sally or is this actually your,
um,
so about two months ago,
yeah.
She messaged me saying she always wanted to learn how to play guitar and that
she finally bought one at this.
She wants,
she's into you do.
I've been playing guitar for years,
so I told her I'd be happy to meet up with her and show her some easy stuff to
get us started.
It slowly morphed into this thing where every week we meet up after work for a
couple hours.
I teach ELL teacher courts and stuff and we'll talk about life in general
anyway.
I noticed lately that a good chunk of the conversations,
right
about how she's been fighting with her boyfriend,
the same guy as when we first met.
Yet how many more fucking signals to your need?
Jesus crisis.
You can not put Christmas lights around her fucking vagina there.
Um,
she's also keeps telling me how amazing on being for teaching her guitar.
And I'm such a great guy.
Plus the last few week if ever boyfriend calls and we're together,
she's been sending it straight to voicemail.
Okay.
All right.
What,
what,
what does she have to do?
Grab you by the back of your neck and fucking push your face towards her?
I mean,
come on,
I'm starting as this guy goes,
I'm starting to get the feeling she might be interested,
call me crazy,
but this is where I need your advice.
I tend to overthink things.
Uh,
yeah,
I would say that because I tend to overthink things a lot in general and it
actually had issues with anxiety slash depression in the past.
I was wondering if you and Nia could help me out here and I'm reading,
am I reading too much into things or does it seem like she's actually showing
some interest?
I'll take any help on what I should do here.
Congrats on your lovely daughter and getting the show picked up for season
three.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Yes sir.
Jesus Christ.
You're low self esteem jackass.
Yeah,
she's in to you.
So what do you mean what you should you do here?
Just I would tell her how you feel.
Okay.
I would just say,
listen,
I hope I'm not out of line here.
I know you have a boyfriend.
Yeah,
I would.
I would just ask her.
I said,
so what's going on with your boyfriend?
You don't seem happy.
You know,
you're always sending it to Tennessee and you're always fighting your sending it
to the voicemail.
You know,
you don't seem happy,
happy.
And this is a 40% chance there's,
she might cry
when she finally says No.
MMM.
And just say,
listen,
I really liked you and I don't,
I don't like seeing you unhappy.
All right?
And not for nothing.
You have a broke up with that guy.
I'd love to take you out sometime.
Now would you like to learn how to do what?
Half court?
That's it.
How about that?
Fs?
Fuck me.
Yeah,
that's what I would do.
I just asked you about her relationship and she's going to say it's not going
well,
and then just say,
you know,
just say what the fuck I just said it.
Put it in your own words.
Alright,
what am I seeing?
Or No de Bergerac over here?
Is that the right guy that the guy tell you the man hit back?
I remember that.
What was it that was at Bronnie?
Did you feel booby?
All right.
I gotta go to the fucking airport and it's nine o'clock.
We'll get picked up in 45 minutes and I haven't even packed you up or had my
fucking breakfast sandwich there.
MMM.
Oh,
that's it.
That's it.
Yeah,
that is it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I will check in on you on Thursday and I'm going to go home today.
I'm going to watch the Formula One race.
That's what the fuck come.
But no,
I'm not.
I'm landing and I'm going strictly
into the,
uh,
F is for family shit.
I gotta go back and start writing again.
Okay.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you
on a,
I already said this on Thursday.
All right,
bye.